we Alan Jones author of our America life
and death on the south side of Chicago
what's your book about the book is about
me and a friend Lloyd's Newman's life
growing up in ITB Wales a house
development on the south side of Chicago
is basically transcriptions of two
documentaries that we did get a life 101
and remorse to 14 stories of Eric Morris
which we had over 100 hours of tape and
we put them in the book format and we
updated it with 50 hours more tape to
you know bring you up-to-date on things
that happen in both documentaries how
old are you now I'm 18 years old
when did you start all of us I started
this when I was 13 years old how did it
start uh I was doing speaking for an
organization called no Toby strat
foundation and I was going around I was
speaking for the organization I'm still
I'm still currently the national doing
spokesperson as well as a board member
what scenarios no dope Express
foundation no don't explain yes and
David I say and then the independent
producer from National Public Radio had
called and asked if the organization had
anybody that could talk about their
community and mr. King the president of
the organization he recommended me to
mr. Issa and I talked to him on the
phone I talked to him for a couple of
days and he asked me I had to have
anybody that would like to pair myself
with and then I brought Lloyd Newman
whom I've known since the first grade
who's David I sir David I said is a
freelance producer for National Public
Radio and who is your your friend Lloyd
Newman Lloyd Newman he's a friend I've
known for the majority of my life we
went to grammar school together we were
known each other since the first grade
and I couldn't find myself who I knew
very well and I felt comfortable with
doing the work that we needed to do
forget her life what was the first time
your your
documentaries ended up on NPR they ended
up on a net in Nashville radio at all
aired March 1993 get her life 101 what
was the reaction the reaction was
stunning people it uh it shocked people
it it caused a lot of controversy what
people thought that David I say who was
a white producer had on somehow
made me and me and Lloyd talk to
everyday what they thought that there
was no impossible that we could have
known the things that we knew what the
age that we were coming from the
circumstances that we were where do you
live in Chicago I live in a housing I
don't live in the projects but I live a
half a block away and on Oakwood and
Lloyd lives in ITB Wales those who've
been in Chicago know downtown Michigan
Avenue the big skyscrapers how far are
you away from all that I'm probably less
than probably two miles away which way
south two miles south have you lived
there all your life I lived all eighteen
years my life what's what's your family
like my family I was raised by my
grandparents and my mother I have two
sisters
I have uncles I mean it's a typical
family life I would say where's your
father I've never met my father you have
any idea who he is uh my mother's told
me who he is but I've never met him face
to face nor engaged in conversation with
them what do you think of that well it
when I was young it upset me but I'm
older now and had to roll with the
punches I can't you know sit here and
wonder about what might happen if or
could I just have to keep living and
keep stepping What's Your Mother like my
mother
she's great now she had a few mishaps in
her life with her mental illness but
she's doing great now kind of mental
illness to Jenna she has she wasn't mad
at Hughes the manic-depressive did you
talk to her about that I guess I talked
about her with her in the book and then
on a documentary where jasker just basic
questions that I would ask whenever I
got curious and what would she tell you
she tell me the truth honest truth did
she care that this was going to end up
in a book like this she then she knew it
was gonna end up in the documentary no
one knew that it was going to end up in
the book
not even me when we begun that we had
started this we didn't think they would
you know how to have them out to this
who are your best friends in the world
best friends I'm Steve I have a friend
that I played football with I have I
mean I believe I've been blessed with
friend to have a lot of good friends lo8
where's Lord today Lloyd's at home he
broke his c-bro
a growth plate in his knee and he
couldn't he was not able to make it
because the doctor thought who was on
stay with him to walk on it as you know
in the book it says it's your voice
mostly yes why yours not his I believe
that more a talking late I'm more I'm
more more step front than Lloyd Lloyd as
more of a quiet person he's more of a
seer I'm more of a seer and adore have
you always been a talker majority of my
life where did you get that do you think
I just believe that I express myself
very well and I and no way I mean people
allow me to talk because I had something
to talk about when I was younger I would
always engage in conversation with
adults when I was young when I was ten I
would again conversation with grown me
in because I felt as though that was the
only way that I could gain knowledge and
you're against our understanding of the
world since I didn't have a father and
my grandfather worked that's the only
way that I truly learned how I was and
what a man was supposed to do and how a
man you know was supposed to survive who
is this woman in this picture that's my
grandmother miss Jim Jones and where is
she today she's at in Chicago probably
with my nephew and my little cousin
Bobby what's she like she was Stern when
I was younger she's she's very nice very
lovely lady and what role did she play
and making you you think what you are
today he played a major role after my
mother was declared manic depressive
when I was about four or five and we
were put in the state custody me and my
older sister my grandmother instead of
letting the state of Illinois take us
and make us you know foster kids my
grandmother stepped in and she took over
and she raised me my sister under her
care till till from five to the present
day what's your sister's name
well sisters Janelle and how old is she
this is 21 she'll be 22 in July July 11
I please how do you two get along I say
we are right we're not you know them
when I you know great sister and brother
pair but yeah we get along what does she
do she's I think she's going to school
trying to get her associate's degree
she's trying to work in you know provide
for herself you mentioned your friend
Steve early
yes why do you like Steve Steve he's
he's a he's like Lloyd but he's more of
a thinking me and him can dialogue what
are you dialogue about dialogue about
everything we dialogue about the world
we'll dialogue about folks with a
dialogue about people leaders philosophy
religion the dialogue on a lot of things
you've got a glossary of terms at the
beginning of this book here if I can
find him and I want to ask you about
some of these terms whose idea was it to
put the glossary of terms I felt that it
was basically all of our idea because
people like to have Ebonics and thing
like that it's not saying that we were
less educated from the community we come
from it just to be dialogue in different
terms if you were to take a kid from
Alabama and put him in Chicago the
dialogue is totally different from what
he's accustomed to what I'm accustomed
to
and yet we knew in the book it was going
to be in our words in a way that we
spoke and we focused over how that is so
people could translate it and understand
let me ask you to find some of these
words booster booster that's like they
they'll go downtown and they'll I don't
know how to get the clothes they like
that but they'll have like new clothes
and things like that
there's a person yes a person they'll
have like new clothes shoes and things
like that and they'll sell them to you
at a very very discounted price and
we'll sell them to you for what stores
sell them to you for else Allah tell you
like very low how do you find a booster
where are they basically no you'll find
them because they they usually add to
barbershops let me know people to spend
the money to hair salons walking up and
down the street hey do you know any
boosters yourself yeah people and no
boosters they make a lot of money they
make a decent living it keeps them it
keeps them happy I mean it's something
it's entrepreneurship it's a steady
business form they sell hair braids
socks lighters and things like that and
it keeps them making money how old are
they usually they're usually anywhere
from know 25 to 50 25 to 60 you'll see
great grandparents out there selling
things like that because it's a business
how did you use the the name booster in
your book I believe we use booster to
describe how some kids might get close
am i no boosters might go knocking
door-to-door
you know having dated a white half of
sale you're buying from a booster yeah
gym shoes maybe a t-shirt lend me a
joggers good hearing their next term is
crib crib that's why you stay it's like
a baby crib that's your house I'm going
to the crib
what's your crib like crib crib is I
mean and what's yours like crib is all
right I mean I got my own room
everybody's happy you by yourself you
know in there in the room yeah have a
nice-sized room TV nice stereo and if
you've got time on your hands to do
anything you want to do what do you do
usually lift weights I like sports I
like athletic even like athletics are
just like competiveness
so I'll usually work out lift weights
how tall are you 5 8 are those biceps 15
and a half 16 inches Daryl Holmes
that's two that's a high ride how to
bewilder partners I did be what you know
I to be wells was I to be wheels was of
black abolition not of like I was she
was a rider in the south and she was
riding the free not free slaver yet in
Jim Crow invent like that around 1900
1910 she was a writer in Chicago as well
as in the south if you were right about
lynching in the south and what's named
after her of it's a sub-project we call
it a project it's a lower income
development that were established in
1940 by the city of Chicago and it was a
great great community then now it's
developed nough something totally
different what's different about it a
lot of gang activity a lot of selling
drugs a lot of poverty a lot of
hopelessness the next term is you said
it was Darrell Holmes and it's da rrow
and what again what does that mean in
connection with either Ewell's Darrell
Holmes I don't know who Darrell is but
it's a narrow forcing story as four of
them it's 414 story high-rise apartments
and that's where they start building in
Chicago around 50s and 60s because they
wanted to build people going vertical
instead of going horizontally and spread
them out over the city so Daley
daily senior he built them any Mayor
Daley yeah Richard Daley father who's
now the Mary's father Richard hey daddy
senior he built them and now they're
they're being torn down he built some
30-foot fall the way the 55th it's a
stretch of about I don't know how many
buildings but yet they're now tearing
them down because they see that there
and there's no use for them a lot of the
dozens I run down in a bad condition and
how come you never lived in the projects
I lived in the projects for my mother on
the west side and Henry Horner for a
while
I had a aunt estate in there but my
grandmother and grandfather my dad the
house that I live in now has been in my
family's just didn't sense to me at 30s
so my great-great grandmother lived
there and we've just houses just went
down generation to generation do you
feel any differently when you're in the
projects versus where you live now I
mean in your own head you feel better or
worser I feel I mean don't get me wrong
where I live is not a great situation
but it's a lot better than what most
kids live in next on the list is deaf
homes d EF that's just uh that's the way
we pronounce Darrell halls deaf homes
that's what the Darrell homes lot of
deaf homes
why do you pronounce it that way you
know that's I believe the guys came up
with that around like 1988 89 that's
when it was like deaf deaf uh I can't
move LL Cool J like death death was a
word and it was afraid that a lot of
guys use in the community I'm saying
like if I said just shoes with deaf it's
not saying that you can't hear it's just
saying that you got you know that's deaf
clothes what you got on that means they
look good that's deaf getting that's
around the time that that word came out
to use kotelko day he was one I think it
was Def Jam Records and the word is
judge it was just used in rap music and
in the community so they said deaf homes
if if I were to hang around you and just
even and Lloyd and you were all talking
the language would I understand you you
would probably understand it depending
on how we use it does mean it's gestures
I mean you would know how I'm using it
how I would what kind of gesture just
know how I mean
I could sit in it so many different ways
doing just know by the way were acting
on what I mean it's a different way to
say what I mean
it could be could be said many different
ways are you happier using your own
language that we've talked about here or
being like you are now I wouldn't say
that I know the trend I just trend I
wouldn't know no one for another because
when I'm around people that have to be
distinguished and I have to use language
that I'm using when I'm relaxed and I'm
at home then I'm using I use both of
them I don't I don't see the transition
next on the list dummy bag dummy bag is
like phony cocaine it's like what it's
like they might take something that
looks like cocaine or a rock or drugs
and it's a dummy bag it's not the real
thing and a hype you might die might be
an expert this is drug addict got hype
might buy it and it's a dummy bags no
really it's not really drugs it's a
dummy bag and they gave money and they
go to the next spot so they really
making money for selling nothing
something that's not real what happens
when you find out you've been sold a
dummy bag I know some people have gotten
killed but selling dummy bags have you
ever had any drugs I've never had to
take him or use him never had to sell
him either getting interest in taking
you know I mean I was curious about him
but it was never to the point where you
know I just went and did it how many
people have you known that have taken
drugs numerous what's the reason they
give you for taking them I believe some
of them just wanted to be accepted
anybody tell you that a lot they liked
it a lot
some people would like you but they
don't know the reasons for which they
like they like it because everybody else
does it's a it's a fad it's a it's a
trend how important is to drug taking to
people you know in their lives I would
say so it's a it's a small minority but
yes they do it they do it you know has
gay parties and things like that if you
took the drugs out of your out of our
society or out of your neighborhoods or
whatever you know different lives you
lead what impact do you think it would
have on the country I don't believe that
you could do that
there's no way possible as to some
people that's the way they relax if you
go in back in time you know a lot of
different cultures and in Japan and
China you know they smoked him and you
know and opium and things like that and
you that's that's where the way people
relax I mean if you take out drugs and
that means you have to take out tobacco
we have to take out alcohol and
different things like that and you do
that's the way people relax that's the
way people I don't believe that it can
be something done on your list you have
n ze e n D s that's money you have some
money in your pocket and you just got
ins where did that word come from you
think I don't know where it comes from
button know is you guys from is it hard
to come by somebody your age eighteen
DRF job yeah I know a lot of people that
work about you for me have a book that's
something and I'm going to college so
that's that's my job
that's why I come down collect my ends
is this your first book yes it is
is this your first job notice on my
first job I worked with ordination of
Express that was my first job and we're
whereas no dope Express headquarters
it's in Chicago and Atlanta you get paid
to work there I was I do speaking things
freephone but out in the summer I worked
for him like my freshman in high school
how did you get into it they worse they
came through my grammar school they were
like there they came through and they
did a workshop for about six weeks and
then how did you get in me and the
president of the organization had an
altercation and an incident and he saw
that I wasn't going to bow down he was
doing about Alice therefore we found a
mutual respect and we end up being very
tight you know he's like family to me
and I'm like family to him
what's his name Earl King and what was
your altercation over I was in a
classroom laughing because I when I was
younger if you heard my CD ghetto life
you hear that I had a very I didn't
sound and have a deep voice now I had a
very childish voice and I had a steel
how like a chipmunk laugh I left like
Alvin the chipmunk and so one day he had
told me to stop laughing like Alvin the
chipmunk so I got up in front of the
whole class and I said you know could he
call me
Alvin the chipmunk I got in front of the
whole class and I stood up and I raised
my hand and I told him I said if you
call me by my name Lee Alan Jones you
know I believed that you were going to
be a better response for me because my
name is not Alvin the chipmunk now that
he saw that I had was stand up to him he
respected it and then how did you turn
that into working for no dope express
well that summer I would he would guy to
have anything all I was doing the son
was playing baseball and running around
the neighborhood he would come get me
and take me out you know go out to eat
his wife was working at a radio station
it's just got a very prominent radio
station there and he would take me out
there where she worked
taking me around and that's when I
became began you know can't find their
organization and began working for the
organization the organization took me on
my first flight when I was in eighth
grade my first flight was to Washington
my first airplane flight what do you
think of that it was I was kind of
nervous at first but now that I got on
you know it's been 50 or 60 more says 50
or 60 more cents
that's what kind of places have you been
overseas at all having been overseas up
into Canada my grandmother took me there
when I was younger she we drove the bus
that I want to kind of been a Miami San
Antonio up and down the East Coast so
when you join no dope Express yes and
you go out where where do you speak I
speak to young people I try to motivate
them I try to motivate adults that's
what I've begun doing you know
motivational speaking what's the first
thing you tell them when you start to
talk to him I asked him to look at look
at themselves and look at me I didn't I
mean today I'm dressed in a nice suit I
mean five six years ago I had no idea
that I could even be on c-span with
Brian lamb there was nobody possibly I
could believe that could be dressed here
and yet and have this book but yet I was
I worked hard I did the right things and
this is what it's led to then what are
you telling I tell them that you have to
work hard there's no way to say you know
that's like me going to college and
thinking that you know our America is
going to let me continue to go through
college and just be a a decent student
know how to
to work hard I have not reached a point
where I can't you know I don't how I can
stop working and I believe well you know
what I have goals now must reach those
goals and you know set goals and work
hard to get there how long is your
speech my speeches can go from 15 to as
long as it takes I usually can go as
live I've went 45 minutes to an hour
telling stories mmm I tell them stories
you know it's fun it's not like I'm
going to sit there and be just a regular
speaker I walk around I motivate I let
kids get around me I'm not the type of
speaker I talk and after to speak after
the form I'm lon
I sit around in dialogue I try to get in
one-on-one conversations what do you do
if somebody's eyes are closed
I've never really see experience that no
one's ever gone to sleep on immigrants
I've never had I've never seen anyone
look asleep while speaking has anybody
ever been hostile to you they've been
hustling in beginning but at the end
they humble themselves and what's the
reason they're hostile because they some
another about ten dollars times mighty
hostile it's somebody who has come from
the background that I've come from I
feel that there's nothing that you know
I could talk to them about but out this
over with you know we same phone numbers
and are we talking to phone at what
point in your speech when you make your
presentation do you see them begin to
change I do I think they see a change
soon inside before I speak it's just a
president seeing someone after they
found out that I'm 18 have to
documentaries or Peabody at Kennedy
president I have all these accolades
behind me all these things that I've
done and yet I'm only 18 they're there
their eyes begin to open when they start
hearing introduction who are some of the
most important people you've ever met in
your life most important I would say
what my mother if it weren't for her I
wouldn't be here she's a very important
lady and her what's her first name June
she's June Jones jr. she you see to see
my grandmother her have the same name
and who's this that's my mom
when was that picture day that picture
was taken probably in September by John
Brooks a photographer
and John Brooks gets credit in this book
for most of the photography yes he's
only about two pictures and aren't his
who is he he's a photographer from
Cabrini Green a guy who comes from the
same situations as me and Lloyd and he
was in he's a self-taught photographer
how old is it
now I'm Brooks is about 22 20 22 years
old go back you said your mother isn't
the most important person and who would
be other people that you remember me to
say that if in social things for our
social status I've met a minister louis
farrakhan dr. benjamin shavers dr. Bobby
Austin of the Kellogg Foundation I see I
think the president of the University
while I'm going to which is a broad
sandy Dalembert a Florida State why did
you pick Florida State I met the
president actually at American Bar
Association meeting in Orlando Florida
c-span actually covered that too in
Orlando Florida last year and I was a
panelist there and his wife Patti Palmer
had saw had saw me on the list and she
had a tape of my documentary in her
purse and she wrote a note to my
grandfather who accompanied me to
Florida in Orlando and wrote that she
was the wife of the president Florida
statements he had a copy of my work and
that she would like to talk to me and
set up maybe a visit to Florida State
and blah blah blah blah blah so I got
the letter went back up went back to my
hotel room called and frantically we set
up breakfast the next morning one of my
visits in October and I was a seminar in
December so what he gonna study
I probably major in criminology tend to
do what I believe that I can I want to
get my doctorate so I believe that
criminology or maybe some other fields
I'm saying criminology now because
that's what I'm most familiar with go
back to your speech that you give what
kind of kids did you talk to
I talked to kids from all different
situations off talking to kids in
Winnetka Illinois which is a
predominantly white school with 4,000
students no 17 African Americans who
never had the experience
african-americans or poverty I was
talking to
kids and come from the same situations
as me I've talking to kids at a Evanston
Township High School with the suburban
in north and we're done
Northwestern University is there I've
spoken to adults I've spoken to a
corporate philanthropist what's the
difference in the reaction that you get
from talking to white kids versus our
kids I believe both they'll both in the
same way white kids are surprised
because they kind of they don't know how
because not go there I'm not in this
attire I go there because I want to
break a stereotype I want them to see
that every kid every black kid is not an
athlete it do there are some no smart
african-american kids out there they're
you know black kid is not a gangbanger
you know that there are some successful
you know black kids and for black here
that you can't be successful to motivate
them to work harder to know that you
can't accomplish something so what's the
difference in the way that my kids react
to you they react my presentation I'm a
totally different first I let the kids
know that I still can relate with them
because a lot of them they get to
misconception that you know I've gotten
to a certain point wife you know where I
can might be a you know I might because
I'll touch still talk proffer when I'm
with their and that's what we call it
when I come from we talking properly
it's not you know it's not you know
regular lingo I mean the not are kind
proper is talking with the language or
talking the way we're talking way we're
talking right now we're talking proper
we're talking proper it's called
you know you're talking white but
reality I still talk this way yet I
still can relate to them on certain
terms I can relate to on all bases of
life and yet I can show them that you
can't be successful I can you know I
don't date a lot of them can relate to
me like this but a lot of them can't you
know I'm talking I'm talking to third
graders by the way you've got a suit and
tie on today are you happier wearing
that or would you rather be in the just
a casual clothes right now I'd rather
you know I like some ties yeah I like
sometimes it's very hot here today but
you know I like sometimes
tighten this down that's right back to
some of the language
flip flip that could mean and you see
you could be looking kid you could be
flipping on the mattress putting little
chairs around the community people who
move out right throw the old mattresses
out the little kids a jump on them and
flip now tumble that's what we call
they'll tumble is that something you do
really when you're really young you can
do it I mean from young to very old I
mean we do a lot of it is yes so that's
a that's a great activity a lot of kids
get a lot of good work out doing that
they flip a lot of my good flips a lot
of them are very great flippers I mean
they they don't have the luxuries of a
of a gym or something like that where
they can go in and have like cushion you
know flooring and have no gentleman
didn't stay like that so therefore they
make deal with what they have so they
flip on old mattresses and things like
that and it's excite to watch kicking it
as means we're just out you know if I
don't we don't say you know so we're
going out on a date I might ask her out
let's go kick it kick it means let's go
out to the movies in my let's go get
something my let's go to the lakefront
and my just admit it just means going
out do you date a lot I would say when I
had time you like it yes it's good it's
healthy but what do they think of your
celebrity I'm not a celebrity so not
this mean it's cool I try to get away
from that did you find a lot of people
your age would listen to the radio
reports on in here a lot of them
actually I was quite I was in shock but
a lot of them who didn't hear it on NPR
the original broadcast whenever the CD
is played because we have Anna city in
hate whenever they hear it they love it
but yet it's not played on mainstream
stations whereas they can you know hear
it in entirety but when they hear it in
their classrooms it's something it's
funny to them it's real to them and it's
something they can relate to
that's when I'm talking about
african-american kids kids who who come
from the environment I come from and
just after Milan kids in general it's
funny there's something they can relate
to
when white kids here is
funny but yet it's shocking because a
lot of them never had to deal with some
of the things that we've had to deal
with it never had to deal with someone
shooting in the field and running and
ducking but if we're shocking and yet
some things they can relate to and a lot
of things they can't but if I try to
bridge I try to build a bridge between
the two another turn my hair is light up
light up but lit up that's the way we
would say it lit up that mean you get
expelled Li gh t he misspelled it lit up
means you got shot you got mean cuz you
got lit up now how about 10 you did lit
up me you know if you go on the street
man let's say I lit up last night that
means you get shot your ass anybody shot
I've never had to see that sight but
I've seen the after-effects up how often
I saw maybe a lot when I was younger but
now since I've as you say protocol got
celebrity status now I'm not around a
community a lot I haven't had to really
experience that you remember the first
time you saw it I'm at the first time I
heard it not all the time the first time
I saw it yeah where was that it was
right on 41st which is right down the
street from my house but what were the
circumstances this guy was on a payphone
and it's made it roll by it was a drive
on he shot him and you were right there
I mean you came right after that I came
right out I heard the shooting because
you know bullets don't have a name on
the one you had a first shot you get
away from it so I thought saw him shot
and it was like well glad it wasn't me
how old were you I'd be about 10 or 11
what impact did that have on you I could
say it it didn't hurt me
yeah Nate was just you know he got shot
that's the way we that's where I believe
I deal with in a lot of other people do
it he got shot what's the worst thing
you've ever seen
worst thing the story aired Morris the
five year old we got thrown out of the
window I didn't actually see him fall
yet I want to look at the story and I
and I read reports it's the worst side I
saw that I've put in my mind who was
Eric Morris Eric was a five year old who
was thrown out of a 14 story window in
October of 1994 by two 10 and 11 year
olds
whose name we can't use because they're
minors they were thrown out
he was thrown out allegedly because he
didn't steal candy didn't steal candy
for he didn't steal candy for the 10 and
11 year olds so the young Eric and his
brother Derek hit went to tell their
mother will internal to go tell the
older kids mother and yet the kids got
angry and we're going to get them back
for telling on them or if you calling
the book tricking on them so they led
him to a 14 story vacant apartment which
they called club house and we've got a
picture we're going to show her that is
from that 14 story yes that's the look
from the fortune story when did this
happen what year this happened in 1994
and did these two young 11 and 10 year
olds and tend to drop the five year old
from the fourteenth story um we never
talked to them so we I can't I can't
speculate but he did fall did you know
Eric Morris I didn't know Eric nor
everything more personally but I've
known his family
I know I've known his sister I've known
some of his relatives this is the
picture where he actually fell st that's
what the end result come falling
fourteen stories was he dead when he
when he hit the ground I don't believe
he died on impact but he died soon after
that why did you want to investigate
this because it was a sad story and I
knew that mainstream media was not going
to get the true story they were going to
do superficial reports when does the
incident you know sensationalized in it
no of the candy in that but they was
they weren't going to indefinitely look
at the kids who did it or I mean no one
interviewed Eric Morse's mom we would
only any of you granted to me this
Morris this is the actual 14th story
that's a 14 story at the 14th floor and
where is this this dusted deaf homes and
the Daryl Holmes
whichever one you may prefer to call it
in the I to be welded ugly wheels now
that it building actually is being torn
down you think that's a good idea
it's it's you know it's a little bit too
late but I'm glad it's coming down why
because it's a day they never really
served their purpose they were put up
there and say they were put up there
cheaply first of all and yet it's a sad
sight
and once you live in those conditions I
mean do they start out as being nice
buildings some of them do yes what
causes them to deteriorate
I believe that lack of jobs you know
respect something we don't feel when you
feel disrespected know you hey gang
infestation and things of that nature
here you are at the beginning of that
section on Eric Morris with your friend
yes Lloyd Newman and what's he like
Lloyd Nolan he's a as you can see is a
he's a good guy he's a good guy he had
maybe some some fairly bad circumstances
at an early age like what his mother
died he was I think 10 or 11 of a shower
pancreas busted I think he I think she
was an alcoholic I don't know for sure
but and what did that do do that Lloyd
Newman that left him to be really raised
by his two older sisters who were at the
time 16 and 17 years old and what did
that turn out to be that turned out to
be a a situation where they had to
become stronger he had to become more of
a man and an early age so what are you
two guys do and you got free time we
really I really have free time to really
have fun like we did we young either I'm
working out trying to better my game at
football or I you know speaking when I'm
resting being around my family so but
when we do get to sit around and talk we
usually look at the things that we used
to do go back to your story on Eric
Morris how long did it take you to
investigate this it took us
approximately a year a year in a couple
months how did you go about it we went
about it just going around the community
interviewing people who we thought had
good stories about Eric who knew
something about the case I mean we had
to wait on interviews with their parents
the only interview one parent I believe
and that was uh one of the young men who
to work out of the windows father what
was the purpose
your investigation to getting in to look
at the look at the whole story because
if you followed the case for anyone out
there who knows the case
President Clinton even spoke on it
senator Dole and all the you know
Congress majority and all the houses
spoken in sanity's kids were it would
there were super predators when in
reality was that it's you know you look
at track record before even October 1994
they had they had bad situations but no
one stepped in to intervene and stop a
situation like that ever happen so
reality is I don't look at them I can't
say a kid is a super predator first of
all that's like me saying that you know
a kid who first comes out of the womb is
damned reality is they're putting damn
situations so in reality you have to
survive and they had to condition
themselves to survive at an early age
where are these kids today they became
the youngest kids able to be locked in
maximum security prison where I don't
know the actual penitentiary why do you
think they got maximum security because
it's younger people crimes started
becoming more prevalent in younger age
groups so I guess it's uh they're using
the kids as as uh so as showing what's
going to happen is up you know poster
boy if you commit a crime or murder
something like that amazing crime at
that age that you will be prosecuted and
you will be sent to jail as you were
investigating this murder as they decide
it was a murder yesterday they will
commit they were uh convicted of a
second degree or first degree I don't
know what degree murder he was where
were your reports where do they people
hear them people heard them on neither
Grady a lot of people threaded in
newspapers do you have people in the
media that you admire and you follow are
there people that you pattern yourself
after or is this all your own idea I
believe that I look at certain people
far as I mean that's one reason why I
jumped on get her life so much I looked
at people like Brian Gumbel
who else dan Rather that's the reason
that I know how to conduct myself
interview nobody's ever sat down to talk
told me you know this is what you doing
interview and it's how you conducted I
just watched a lot of TV and I saw how
it was supposed to be done and how are
you and you have to be a little bit
curious do you ever watch this network
that's all while she spent what do you
watch I watched a lot of times I watched
the Senate I watch the house when
they're talking like when Alan Greenspan
is on talking about economy and what do
you see when you're watching it what are
you hear what do you learn I'll see that
they have no idea of what goes on in our
America when they talk about no tax cuts
and capital gains things like that I
look at it as how this is this really
going to affect people in my community
how is it going to help their
circumstances I mean how is a flat I
mean the flat tax gonna help now I look
at it that way and I try to interpret it
that way what would you tell them if
they ask you to come testify I've
testified before the Congressional Black
Caucus
I can testify last year and I talked
about on crime and young young I don't
know the description of the test of me
Ted's fine we get of testified did you
like that it's okay I mean it didn't
change anything it was something that
changed the situation of poor people and
kids growing up in a situation I'm going
to that I grew up in yeah I would like
it but you know what's it like if it
doesn't change anything if if I was the
person that was about self gratification
and self Lorre and self proclamation and
yes I loved it but no it's not a kind of
big thing for me to be on TV or have a
book it's not going to make change and
help people by the way how did the
actual book work did you did they write
a contract with you and they pay your
money to do this or it was done like any
other book was not what does that mean I
mean how did it start it started out
there was a bit we had a agent who set
out a bid and Scribner did the highest
and we we were contract to do the book
who shares in that profit how many
people are involved in this it's a
three-way split between David I say me
and Lloyd Norman and what will it do for
you the money coming in but what do you
want to do with the money one thing I
hope to do you know before I die before
I wish I could do it now is help my my
grandmother my grandfather eyes one of
my family just I wouldn't I wouldn't
move just fix the conditions about let's
fix the house let's make sure our house
is if he can last another 60 to 70 years
to where I can raise my great grandkids
in there like they've raised us how old
are your grandparents my grandmother is
65 my grandfather 71 but your
grandfather like my father is a great
man strong black man he was born in
Arkansas
he was raised in st. Louis he's worked
all his life until maybe up until he had
his first stroke he was a he worked in
Midway he worked in the stockyards in
Chicago and he was a CTA bus driver for
about 25 years and when they if they
watched this interview with you what
whoa based on your experience in the
past what will they tell you after sir
what kind of comments do they make to
you
they ran father I believe in the book
and his interview says I make him feel
ten feet tall because I believe they can
look at me and see all the lecturing all
the weapons they see him you never grew
up did you we got work very bad I was a
very stubborn kid and you remember that
I remember most of Mike remember to laid
about too and stubborn why do you use
the word stubborn what would you do that
was stubborn because I was I'm
independent I never I've never really
looked at anyone and really I was always
independent I would
I rarely I would listen but yet if I
didn't take heed I was uh I was very
knowledge I could I acted too old when I
was younger and I still I'm only 18 and
I've I mean I've always conducted myself
much older they always tried to make me
you know act my age but I just couldn't
how's your book selling by the way I
don't know how cells are I would hope
that they're good if they're not then
you know have you been on the book tour
yes I've been on the books were
it's it's we were in New York it was in
New York Washington and Chicago and the
60 minute thing what was that all about
60 minutes was a they worked on a piece
for about nine months it was about about
me and Lloyd the book about how we came
about doing it thanks for that nature
did you get any reaction um I got a lot
of reaction and what was that after with
the peace of the air that Sunday May 18
that Monday me and Lloyd walking down
the street in Times Square in New York
and this lady he just grabbed us and she
was almost in tears because she said
that she was she saw the piece and she
wanted to get in contact with us and she
was just blessed to meet us other
reaction you got what about your
grandparents your it loved it I mean
after this piece a tear I called home on
I was in New York at the time and I
really couldn't get through because so
many people were calling is it ever
worry that this is going to be too much
for it at age 18 I believe that either
way it goes at 18 being young and
african-american in this society it's
going to be a lot of pressure on my
shoulders so the reality is what I have
pressure on this on this hand or
pressure on the other hand regardless of
the situation is going to be pressure
it's just how you handle it and how you
deal with what is your friend lied
Newman going to do with his life
Lloyd has one more year in high in high
school he plans to graduate and attend
Northwestern which I believe you can if
he works hard
back to the terms the he called a ghetto
glossary another term is a nine oh
that's a pissed that's a 9-millimeter
is that a gun that you find around the
less you that's usually that's two
that's usually the gun and most guys who
street carry knives or maybe I mean
that's that's basic that's the basic gun
right there do you see a lot of morale
yeah majority of the people who were I
mean they have the most power the most
daring most concealable did you ever
want to carry again lot of times for
what reason
or it may I guess it gave you a false a
false sense of pride did it made you
feel big
in what you really were is how hard is
it to get a nine how hard is it it's not
hard I mean money I mean we can get and
you can get anything money can get you
anything these days
how hard is it to get money money money
is mean hey if you look at if you would
go down to my street and you hear all
you see the nice cars and the question
one asks itself but you know money to do
good money to do good it's hard to come
by
you know money to do it for a good
college is hard to come by money for a
bad call is usually very easy to get how
do you get it easy you can hustle you
can be you can be ruthless what's that
mean
ruthless you can just get it by any
means I don't want to say by any means
necessary because I don't want to quote
I don't want to use that quote in that
in this in this in that context pop I
mean you got shot to get pop pop means I
when I say lit up and pop pop me into
that shot you ever shoot you
I don't believe they shot at me
intentionally but I believed I could get
caught up across fire player means you
got a lot of girls you your Mac player
you're a Mac a Mac you know like act you
know pretty Tony max players player can
it planners manager you know your ladies
men I was how player just means way you
carry yourself or you're a Mac who me I
mean I wouldn't I wouldn't I wouldn't
know I can kinda want to characterize
myself like that
pushing Keys means you you're pushing
Keys you're selling kills a coat if you
wanted to go find coke to sells how hard
is it it's not that hard I don't believe
I know the game that's what you call it
when you out that no it's the game I
could win either way in my life again
why do you think you went this way this
way I looked at the pros and cons I
believe that I have them I can look at
things in in parent contrasts compare
and contrast you like a TV you can
contrast it I licked it where
in five years I would be if I went that
way in five years if I went this way and
today I have a book lot I went that way
well I might have prospered but the
reality is I'm hurting my community but
again what do you think you know was
there a person or several people anybody
besides your grandparents your mother
that impressed you to go the other way I
had a lot of mentors and I was younger I
had a two brothers I know they helped me
significantly and I grew up right next
to a university for your brothers names
I did one of my brothers there were two
brothers who helped me they go to where
they grew up in our community Alvin and
Eric Collins and they basically
introduced me to sports and sports was
like a way out for me for about two or
three years I played baseball football
and basketball I just stayed really
active in sports and in very active in
school and just kept me on up and up how
old were they or how old are they now I
was about 35 and it's about 36 37 and
what about them did you like they were
they were men first of all and I knew
that if I wanted to be a man that they
were the best images to look at being a
man my grandfather was a lot older so I
knew his you know I knew he was a great
man yeah he was getting little bit older
and I knew that I was young man and I
saw them it's best resemblance of how I
wanted to fit in society and how I must
live so I looked at them they they were
jobs they you know at times of success
he was a family man
Aven to start he just got his family his
wife and he know his two sons so and
they still embrace me I mean I get
acknowledged them in my book ready they
are ready rocks that's what's happened
after you cook the coal you put in like
a dummy bag a dummy bag is a fake ready
it's supposed to be ready Rock rep like
a reputation rep how strong is your rep
reps what a reputation is what you know
makes you if you got a reputation of
being weak in people gonna try you
and what's your reputation do you think
reputation when I was younger I had a
reputation that I didn't I would fight I
would fight because I was I was very
small I was only about
maybe for 243 and I'll be picked on a
lot but the reality was is that I would
fight regardless of how big or or the
individual was I was going to fight
because I mean I didn't want to have
reputation of being a coward what would
you do today today I don't think I would
fight I don't think I owe myself in the
situation to fight I haven't had a fight
in about three years we have four years
almost since I've been in high school
serving serving means you serving that
ready rock with a dummy bag you like to
you the drug delay you serving you know
you serve you serving like a waiter and
how how rental available is it 30 well
yeah I mean it's like going through your
like getting them Washington Post it's
that easy
how expensive is it expensive depending
on the guys race you can sell them you
can sell you know you sell to you know
yourself you know to dollar hits $2
blows and go all the way up to you know
what you need and what you want now this
next one I it's throughout the entire
book and it kind of brings a smile on
face every time I see it shorty shorty
shorty is what you can sit it when
you're young
growing up in it in the ghetto so here's
a picture of the buddy Shorty's three
Shorty's right where did that term come
from Shorty's I mean shorty you young do
a young man or a young girl shorty when
do you stop being a shorty I mean I
don't know I guess when you saw getting
facial hair because I'm still called
shorty and I'm 18 you're still calling
shorty I'm still called shorty because
I'm 18 is it a is it a term of
endearment or is it you know do people
use it derogatory or no it's it's a
turn-on what's up shorty I mean when I
go up the kids you know that's how that
you acknowledge them shorty over suppler
man that's how you that's how you
acknowledge loose and and Eric Morris
was a shorty it was of the shorty and
how about these two kids under under the
picture it says ghetto kids yeah that
Shorty's shorty what is a ghetto kid
what's a ghetto mean to you get on it's
the environment which I'm around
I think someone asked me to you know
change my phrase and change waited
change the way what ghetto is the only
word I can substitute forget it was hell
these the kids growing up inhale you've
got a picture here from either be Wells
again the development what's this
picture of right here the pitch of the
ghetto I mean that's a picture of
someone who moved out and threw their
furniture out because they didn't day I
mean why take trash like that to
someplace better give any solution is
how you stop those kind of things and
together I believe that you know that
question it took it took it
it took the wheels 20 or 30 years to get
like that now I believe is going to
change like that in one year reality is
I believe is that if we all can come
together and now form and dialogue and
yet you know implement what we get out
of that form and dialogue into that
problem and we will have a solution I'm
not going to sit here and try to be a
sociology and answer that question is
too is too broad when was this picture
taken a picture was taken in 1993 I mean
lo we're doing get a life 101 you
remember this day I remember that day I
really that coat that headphones on I
remember that at Shelby got us in the
pissy when you had this picture taken
were YouTube by yourself as you walked
around uh we were probably wouldn't
probably accompanied by David I say he
go everywhere you went you went majority
replacing the wheels like he like we
went and who is he tell us more about
his day and he's the independent
producer who gave me a lloyd to take the
microphone and tape recorders to go
around you know community and talk about
our life where does he live he lives in
New York City and it just are you still
in touch with him yes yes very much so
and how much did he do to train you to
do what you're doing now trying to do
the technical part of it we did the
reporting part of it did he give you
questions to ask or anything like that
yeah it was question to ask but the
reality was the way he asked questions
the way we asked cuts are totally
different and I mean they were just
things that we already knew we already
imprinted in our mind how many hours
total did you record probably 120 hours
of tape how much of that eventually got
on NPR 30 minutes in one hour and how
many times was that on it was I think
getalife folly I don't know I know there
once or not
considerate and they probably had a few
times after that I no remorse here
wasn't probably a few times out that on
page 153 you say kids around here have
got to have more things to do exactly
how can you say alright you can be great
but yet you can't you don't have the
tools for them to make themselves great
you know that's the only reason I'm here
someone put the tools in front of me
to build something if you have them
tools how can you build it we don't have
a shovel how can you did you can dig
with your hand yeah you need a shovel
you're President of the United States
had all the money available to you to
solve the problems that you've seen in
your life give us some ideas where you
everybody talks about money I believe we
are we have a lot of monies country have
a lot of rich people in this country the
idea is a lot of us just give money kids
I mean like I said money it's not
something these kids it's something that
they need it's a resource we give them
your time I mean time I believe I mean
these kids they need somebody to you
know they know they know money's there
but they need somebody that's going to
show them when they get money and they
get resources how to manage them you
know if I had all the money in the world
you know hey you still could be you know
he still could be a star you know a
person that's you know sad all the money
in the world doesn't make you great and
all the money in the world can't make a
situation you know it can make it better
but can they make it better where it's
going to be maintained if you voted yet
I'll be registering to vote but yet I
look at the political spectrum now and I
look at the voters I know a lot of
african-americans died for us to get to
vote but the reality is I mean unless
until I can see a serious policy rias
not a politician but a serious person
who's who has a big heart and who's
willing to you know take the fullest
ride and not just get sound bites not
just gift photo-ops
who's willing to go in the community and
make a change and make everybody happy
I'm talking about me in poverty I mean
I'm not trying to put a blackface on
poverty that's poor you know white
Americans pork you know Hispanic
Americans I'm talking about everybody
I'm not just talking about my community
and just to focus in on that we're the
only ones who need resources there are a
lot of other communities out there and
they need to step in get in that forum
and make sure that that happens
okay 10-15 years from now where do you
want to be 10 to 15 years I believe that
I should have my doctorate I should have
a family I should hope that this problem
will be slowly regressing I hope that we
I can I can do enough in in 15 years
whereas this problem will not be right
at what it is now 15 years I'll be what
33 33 I'll probably be in my campaign
ready for what
run for president of what of the United
States of America what do you think your
chances are great why cuz into a father
in 15 years I'll be 33 32 my peers will
be the same age majority the people that
I'm speaking to be of age to vote the
from the president I believe the
president in the next the president's
role is changing this country is no
longer strictly conservative strictly
you know get out and get votes you have
to have a genuine interest in people and
you must understand you know people who
vote you at it you understand who you
vote for like Bill Clinton people
understand him
people understand him in the rural South
people can understand him and working
hard again but if you look at the way
politics is going to change with the
constituency a lot of these kids going
to be young I mean it's going to be
vibrant so therefore they won't smile is
going to represent that in their best
interest now in 10 to 15 years I hope
that that turns out and it plays out the
way that I see it this is the cover of
the book it's called our America and
it's co-authored by Lee Allen Jones our
guests and we thank you very much thank
you very much